I think people overlook that this is a
medicine and in this a healing medicine
is right here every weekend it's like a
car wreck and there's only one test
right in a way the FL is kind of like
you know they're just looking away so we
know everybody here in this round table
smokes some cures behind the stories of
how y'all's first experience of smoking
was first time you smoked I was in high
school probably about you know 17 years
old
you got tied up with some of those
skater girls you know he's the kind of
joke around with me like I was a kind of
a square you know so I had to go prove
myself I was 16 I was at an Aerosmith
concert and and kiss too and I had a
bunch of friends ever smoking and we
smoked from the parking lot passed out
on the lawn for all of kiss but woke up
for Harrison a great concert first time
was and the sixth grade a couple of
neighborhood boys that was since then
she wrote first time I was in college
and I don't think I really felt it the
first time but there's one time we
smoked out of an apple and man I was I
was so hard never last time of my life I
guess on the subject of also smoking the
N you guys smoke while you guys are
active in the lead
I used to throughout my career
definitely for a sleep big for me and
just paying management as well this
trying to recover relax and decompress
when you coming back on that plane ride
or the night before the game giving you
the ambien ambien
no I ain't trying to get addicted on it
I'd rather this throw me one up smoke go
to sleep when I could sleep peaceful
like I wake up about picking about
players I'm a making the game on Sunday
night it was very helpful for me it was
very helpful like anxiety stress you
know the pain management obviously
that's a no-brainer
so how do y'all play while hi this is
Shawn was what I feel like that's top of
him you see in a movie uh above the room
oh yeah that's how that's how I
literally am on the field yeah just like
it was no stopping me mellow me out got
me going and it's the best thing for me
what was that ritual smoke to bird
before every game sit in the bathtub
with some exercise play my music smoke
eat breakfast with my family and my kids
wife I fired up on the way to the
stadium go through the bad neighborhoods
and whatever team I was playing with to
the city and just reflect like that's my
motivation I'm blessed to be in this
position to get up and go do what I love
by the time tick tock come I'm just at
ease when I'm ready now I'm power I'm
flow
Shawn's Dylan one that said he's played
while hi is anyone else even thought
about it
oh no it was more like a relaxing for me
I feel like I thought played I'll just
be like - like I'm giving up a bunch of
sex this is my man go left or right man
any drug test me in a field in college I
did yeah
I was I was just smoking during the
break you know when you're supposed to
stop yeah and I just kept going and they
did the thing like they were rolling we
came back and like I don't know where
they like okay and drug test
the doctor comes up and he's calling out
the names or whatever and like Moffat
and everyone in the room is just like oh
like it was like I was already done
yeah and took it and they were like my
coach called me in and he was like your
levels were literally like the highest
like the NBA test is four times a year
in the NFL what are the tests like and
when does it happen
yeah it's one time of year usually in
the spring time after uh
before OTAs or right after OTAs start
you know you usually do about groups you
know position group so you know guys are
always hoping to be in that first group
some guys have to wait all the way to LA
you know which is upsetting to some guys
but why is it I've said you know the
rest of your team max is on it so you
want to be able to be on it too so like
you said the NFL knows what's going on
if you fail a test though you know
you're subjected to getting testing you
know ten twenty times a month you know
so they'll punishment is harsh and then
if you fail the test again and again and
again you know then money starts getting
the ball to start taking away a game so
and there's only one test right so in a
way the NFL is kind of like they're kind
of just being like okay
you know they're just looking away but
so that's why I think like things like
this is is what's important because it's
breaking the stigma it's really just the
stigma and power I mean they could just
be like let's get rid of that one test
but really most guys can clean it up for
that amount of time and still have it
during the season I think I think they
know that so how many people do you
think smoking to leave what percentage
do you think at least 80% shoot the
coaches do it personnel people upstairs
do it quarterbacks that do it captain's
your leaders of the team smoke as much
as I do mine even smoke more than me
when you test testing and OTAs and you
pass the drug test what happened
afterwards and I see my name
oh I'm one of the first ones pull my
phone out call my plug is that the house
by the time I get out of practice it's
how you get food trailer camp I mean the
trainer came to me one time like okay
[Laughter]
there's been times where you going off
on the floors on in training camp Hotel
on this Wow everybody do it and you know
everybody has their reason they used it
for that for their pain but he's a big
guy we are big guys my body hurts I've
heard like that Monday morning feels
awful so it's Monday morning like you
guys are getting up rolling something up
and smoking real quick what does the
Monday morning like feel it's like a car
wreck it essentially like every weekend
it's like a car wreck and you start
feeling better about Friday or Saturday
you know it's just it takes a few days
to recover it and start feeling like you
can play again
Tuesdays usually like the day you really
feel it cuz you got all these drugs that
you're putting yourself just to play you
know the toward all the total and all
that stuff so that stuff hasn't even
worn off you buy that by Monday
usually like Tuesday you come you wake
up you like man like the game was a
couple days ago but that stuff is in a
finally out your system now so you
really get to feel the effects from this
past Sunday you know I had an
injury-plagued journey just to the NFL
you know tore my ACL three times so I I
had been on a prescription drug route
early in my life you know I was in a
dark place and I wasn't feeling good and
you know they were never give me those
things readily so it was easy for me to
you know start smoking and receiving the
benefits of you know of marijuana as a
viable option opposed to the
prescription drug so I think people
overlook that this is a medicine and
it's a healing medicine and the rhetoric
hasn't always supported that I mean I
use these topicals all the time you know
for my knees on my shoulders on my back
is that for the like the pain that you
experienced you still do it yes so you
no pain no arthritis any inflammation
there's stuff all for these type of
things yeah as I said it's how I felt
about them topicals oh man like my
granny I guess under my granny's she's
calling me all the time do you have some
more of that cream because it really
works the CBD is a huge market now in
the CBD is without the psychoactive
effects of the THC so that's what CBD is
so now you're getting the effects of
cannabis but you're not getting the
psychoactive effects that make you feel
hot going on the subject of concussions
raise your hand if you have suffered a
concussion the NFL three or four you
have any of y'all smoke while having the
concussion to try and help I did smoke
but I wasn't doing it I didn't think of
connecting it with the concussion I was
being dealing I just I don't know you
know I would hope I've heard the same
similar things that you were saying
about the lubricating kind of thing you
know I mean but like it kind of covers
your brain or it helps the swelling I've
heard the same thing and so I would hope
that smoking did kind of offset it to an
extent did you everything you'd be on
believes before high smoking no no I did
not because I feel like you guys have
reported me for smoking I thought it was
a trap what the inside with the real
everybody's been being hush-hush they're
being fake all the way people gonna find
out about something we speak about and
talk about it just if not you keep it
like a secret house is going to expand
and it all for the world to everybody
understand what cannabis actually does
so the next CBA is 2020 right and I
think it's just something that's just
got to be on the table you know it's a
big change it's not something simple but
the conversation needs to get started
the facts and the resources need to be
brought to the other
and the we'll just need to start
spending more but Bo I mean you also
have an opportunity right now to speak
to Commissioner Goodell what the shoot
like what would you tell him right now
about marijuana just know we've been
demonizing this this plant for so long
so just take the time to do the research
to educate yourself right if you had a
chance to talk to Roger Dale about NFL
players using cannabis what would you
tell him I'll just tell them that you
know I feel like you guys already know
there's a ton of the players who who
smoked marijuana we've only get tested
once a year and why I have that one once
a year tests when you know it's so
beneficial to all the players who use it
and we've speaking with good intention
anyway you know we're not serious I'm
speaking to help my brother's to help
people who are suffering from the same
things that we've suffered the NF it was
a vehicle for us and now it's giving us
this platform to speak you know athletes
are a powerful force you know a powerful
force for change and you know sports can
get it done